rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
découvrir le sentier botanique de la
roche merveilleuse à cilaos
rendez-vous à cilaos prendre en
direction de bras sec
avant d'atteindre le bloc engagez-vous
sur la route forestière de la roche
merveilleuse au pied de laquelle vous
pourrez vous garer
très proche de cilaos le site de la
roche merveilleuse et très fréquenté
pour son point de vue mais aussi pour
son sentier botanique accessible à tous
qui propose de découvrir la partie
méridionale de la forêt de bois de
couleurs du mat à rome
ce
ce sentier botanique a été réaménagé
récemment par le nf en 2009 les nouveaux
panneaux envoie aux formes originales se
fond bien dans le paysage nombreux ils
servent à repérer les espèces décrites
même si parfois il faudra quand même
bien ouvrir l'oeil on parle d'une
fougère un sarment deux d'accord si vous
voulez world fougères sans menteuse
on la trouve la voix la voix somptueuse
qui pendent sur le rocher
ensuite on parle du petit bois d'oiseaux
qui a au pied du rocher et on le voit
bien le bois d'oiseaux qui apparaît ici
et après l'explication fini sur le bois
meg et le bois mais qu'avec son trou un
peu fou qui va épouser la forme de la
roche et qu'on voit tout en haut
au niveau du contenu scientifique la
rédaction de ces panneaux a été confiée
à roger lavergne botaniste
incontournable quand on s'intéresse un
minimum à la flore réunionnaise
chaque panneau apporte donc son lot
d'informations intéressantes mais la
formulation employée tant au niveau de
la syntaxe que du vocabulaire peut
parfois surprendre un registre qui se
veut poétique mais qui parfois à la
limite du compréhensible ne sert pas
toujours au mieux le propos
à la moitié du parcours une descente en
aller retour permet d'atteindre l'un des
plus bel arbre de ce sentier botanique
un vieil accouche imposante faut savoir
que les affiches ont une particularité
c'est que la graine viennent se poser
sur le rocher etc les racines quand ils
vont commencer à englober la roche la
roche en dessous va descendre s'effriter
et laisser le creux à l'intérieur d'une
érosion les racines l'eau le vent tout
ça fait que la roche va partir en mille
morceaux
on voit là d'ailleurs qui commença à
s'effilocher là si vous avez ces deux
blocs là qui s'en vont vous avez la
racine qui va rester dans sa forme
initiale dans sept pays du monde on peut
avoir des affiches qui font 20 mètres de
haut auront un thé dutronc et monte à 1
20 m de haut dans ce trou
sur le chemin retour un banc taillé dans
un tronc de bois permet un instant
de se reposer dans cette dernière partie
du sentier il y à un peu moins de
panneaux et le milieu est moins riche
à deux pas de la ville de cilaos cette
forêt n'est malheureusement pas épargné
par les espèces invasives
ce sentier quand même temps envahi par
des espèces des pestes végétales quoi
notamment là on trouve une espèce qu'on
appelle le longue aux c'est la même
famille que le gingembre lui va pousser
que en dessous le bois mais vu que c'est
une peste végétale y aura tendance à
étouffer lot espèces endémiques ou
indigènes présentes quoi donc
c'est l'un des gros fléau ici à assilah
sa fin dans la forêt si l'os de
pratiquement 1000 à 1500 m quoi
et
juste le temps de jeter un oeil lors de
la forêt par une petite roue et dans la
végétation
et nous voici de retour à notre point de
départ
ce qui est intéressant dans ce sentier
c'est l'aspect plantes indigènes et
endémiques qu'on peut trouver quoi c'est
la richesse un floral qu'on peut trouver
dans ce sentier c'est pas la peine de
partir extrêmement loin pour trouver des
espèces quand même assez rare quoi on
paye elle est où le moment de la journée
mais de préférence moi je vous conseille
de le faire en fin de journée quoi en
fin de journée ou en début d'après midi
c'est là où vous allez rencontrer
beaucoup moins de monde c'est là où vous
allez voir plus d'oiseaux notamment le
maire l'a qui chante à tue tête à chaque
fois dans ce sentier ce que j'aime moins
c'est le manque de point de vue on n'a
pas de point de vue réelles sur sur ce
sentier donc pour trouver un point de
vue on trouve 2
deux points de vue mais faut quand même
c'est quand tu es un peu du sentier
monter sur les rochers pour voir un peu
un peu au loin qu'est ce qu'il ya au
dessus de la canopée qu'est ce qu'il ya
au dessus de cette forêt voilà c'est le
la des paramètres que j'aime moins sûr
sur ce sentier c'est le point de vue
non